-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know best from
"The Bold Type,"
"One Life to Live,"
and Broadway's "Next to Normal."
She's starring in the second
season of "The White Lotus,"
which airs Sunday nights
on HBO and HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-He's so handsome.
He has blond hair
and these big blue eyes.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Chuckling ]
He's really funny, too.
I spend more time with him
than Cameron sometimes
'cause he's so busy at work.
Such a cutie.
Want to see a pic?
♪♪
-This is just a picture
of your kids.
-Is it?
Whoopsie.
-Please welcome to the show
Meghann Fahy, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-Oh, I'm great.
I'm so happy to be here.
-I'm so happy to have you.
I'm also very happy this is
your first time on the show.
But we also -- It's the first
time we've had your family
in the audience,
which is very exciting for us.
-I don't know where they are.
Oh, there they are.
Hi, guys.
-I'm so glad. I was worried
they'd be way farther back.
Be like, "Why did we give them
such bad seats?"
This is great to have you here.
This is the first time
on our show.
But you have been
in this building before,
because there's a very important
person in your life
who is located here.
-That's right.
My dentist.
-Your dentist.
-Yeah, yeah.
-A lot of people don't know
that, but 30 Rock has a lot
of non-show-business people
operating out of here.
-Yeah, and very important
non-business-show people, too.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-And your --
This is a long-time dentist?
-Yeah.
I've been with him for years.
He's my guy.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, let me tell you something.
This is a great
advertisement for him,
because your teeth
look fantastic.
-Listen, I'm not telling anybody
what his name is
because I'm afraid that
he'll become too busy for me.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-And he, you know --
he's saved me
from some pretty sticky
situations.
-Yeah, you had a dentist
actually save you --
a show-business save, right?
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I broke my tooth
actually in half once.
-How do you break
a tooth in half?
-So let me tell you, Seth.
I have no beef
with Poland Springs.
-No. The last thing you want
is a feud with Poland Springs.
-Truly.
-Yeah.
-But I did break
my tooth in half
on a Poland Springs
water bottle.
-Okay, now, can I jump in
and say maybe
you were drinking it wrong?
[ Laughter ]
-So basically, there's,
like, a little pull tab.
You know the bottles that have,
like, the sucky thing?
-Yeah. Like the sort of,
like, sport top.
-Not the twist-off cap.
The sport top, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I was trying to open that.
-They originally called it
the sucky thing,
and then marketing was like,
"Please. Anything."
-"Anything but this."
I was in the elevator bank
of my building at the time
and I was going to an audition
and I was opening my water
and I broke my tooth in half.
-Okay.
-And I just remember
thinking, like --
At no point was I like, "I can't
go to this audition now."
I was kind of like,
"Well, I guess I have to
go to this audition now
with my tooth in my pocket."
So, yeah.
So I put my tooth in my pocket.
And I proceeded to go to
a Duane Reade on 34th Street.
And I asked them
where their nail glue was.
-Wow.
-And they were like, "Aisle 9."
And then I bought the nail glue
and I said,
"Where's the bathroom?"
And they said,
"We don't have one."
And then they said the nearest
bathroom was in McDonald's.
So I was like, "See you there."
I went to McDonald's.
I asked them where
the bathroom was.
They pointed me
in the direction.
And when I got in there,
there was no mirror.
-Okay.
[ Laughs ]
It would have been so awesome --
-'Cause 34th Street.
You know what I'm saying?
-If you had glued your tooth on
backwards, that would be --
[ Laughter ]
So did you have to do it --
just you had to, like,
feel your tooth?
-Well, no, I had, like,
a small compact mirror...
-Okay, gotcha.
Thank God.
-...that I pulled out.
And I nail-glued my tooth
into my mouth
looking into this mirror.
And then I went to the audition.
And I got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't help but noticing
your dentist didn't play a role
in that story at all.
-[ Laughs ] Well, no.
So -- So then --
-You walked in his door
and you're like,
"I don't need you anymore.
I got some glue
from the Duane Reade.
You're not getting my money."
-"What can you do for me?"
But then I did have to
go to the dentist
'cause I needed him
to make it pretty.
It was a little messy.
-I can bet that if we actually
saw a photo from that day,
we would be a little --
-I purposely took none.
-That's very smart.
-Because I was like, "I don't
want to remember this at all."
But, yeah, then I then
went to see him,
the man who is somewhere
adjacent to this building.
And he was like, "What did you
use to put this together?
I can't figure out
how to undo it."
And I was like, "Nice."
-Yeah.
That is an audition you landed.
This is a fantastic story
with a very happy ending
that had a rough middle,
which is you auditioned
for the first season
of "White Lotus."
-I did.
-And got very close.
-Yeah.
-And didn't get it.
-That's right.
-And...
[ Laughter ]
Again, it has a happy ending.
I would never do this
if it didn't.
But were you able then
to watch the first season
of "White Lotus," or was it,
like, sort of too raw a nerve?
-No, oh, my God,
I was such a fan.
I mean...
Like, right off the bat.
I feel like Mike is so good at
picking the exact right person
that you watch the show
and you're like,
"I just can't imagine
anybody else doing this."
And that's exactly how I felt.
And I just feel, like, so lucky
that for whatever reason,
I ended up getting to do it.
Like, it's so cool.
-It's so cool.
You're so wonderful in it.
I think the same is true of you,
which is I don't think anybody
who would've wanted that part
could watch you and think that
it could be done any better.
And you got to spend time
in Sicily.
That must have been
a fantastic place to shoot.
-So much time in Sicily, yeah.
It was amazing.
It was incredible.
-And my friend Aubrey Plaza,
who's wonderful on the show,
as well --
-She's great.
-And someone -- This --
So you guys
went hiking together.
-We did.
-Who was in charge of the hike?
-So it was me, technically.
-Okay.
-It was a place that I had
hiked to several times before,
and then I did get us lost.
-Okay. So you confidently
told her, "I know this hike.
Don't worry."
-100%.
I was like,
"Follow me right over here."
And then we got so lost
that we ended up
sort of walking down
the side of the highway.
-Okay, that's never a good sign
on a hike.
-No, no, no, no.
Yeah, so -- And there was no --
I mean, there's no sidewalk.
It's just you're just sort of
on the road.
And it was kind of funny
because there was
this whole sort of biker gang
that came, like, past us.
And it was a very
Daphne/Harper moment
because Aubrey was like --
They were like, "Hey, girls."
And she was like,
"Don't look at me."
And I was like, "Hi!"
-It is a little unfair to say,
"Don't look at me,"
when you're walking
on the side of the highway.
I think at some point
you want people to look at you,
you know, just out of safety.
-Yeah. She had a bucket hat on.
She was, like,
trying to be really low-key.
And I was like,
"I love it here!"
-Thank you so much
for being here.
I can't wait
for the final episode.
Thank you for not spoiling it.
-Thank you for having me.
-You guys, that's Meghann Fahy.
Season finale
of "The White Lotus"
airs this Sunday at 9:00 p.m.
on HBO and HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."